we have this tweet from clay Travis
someone actually just super chatted clay
Travis tweets Bud Light has fired the
marketing VP who green lit the Dylan
Mulvaney advertisement I'm not going to
read what he said uh as the brand sales
continue to tank that's Alyssa that's
the woman I was just talking about is
she is she the one that criticized uh
Bud light's brand for being too fratty
but then that other video of her surface
being kind of Friday yes it was 20 years
ago about her job this girl doesn't even
like the company she works for yeah
that's a good question why why are
people like that getting jobs and making
calls like this
this girl who doesn't seem to like it
here is the future of our marketing
phase I'm also surprised she didn't get
fired sooner but they are really
struggling it's play Travis is tweeting
it we'll see if we get more confirmation
on that so I wanted to clarify that
there's a difference between boycotting
and canceling in no way has this become
a cancel movement against uh Budweiser
this is a boycott against Budweiser
canceling is when you say don't let them
on that platform
boycott is when you say everyone mute
that account